et vous vous êtes le bienvenu à nos
réunions pour vérifier de vous-même et
si on aaime pas les gosses on peut venir
quand
même
RA bonsoir bonsoir alors ton vrai nom
c'est comment mon nom de naissance c'est
Claude vorillon Claude vorillon ouais
alors raë c'est un surnom d'une certaine
façon raë c'est le nom qui m'a été donné
par ces êtres de l'espace que j'ai
rencontré les ellohim on va y venir
profession de ton père il faisait quoi
de père inconnu h et ta mère ma mère
très gentil h femme à la maison oui
femme au foyer femme au foyer alors tu
dis être re né de l'insémination de ta
mère par un extraterrestre oui j'ai
appris ça quand j'avais 20 29 ans lors
de la deuxème rencontre avec ces êtres
de l'espace et c'était un coup de Massu
sur la tête au départ et puis j'ai
compris par la suite que c'était
simplement comme c'est arrivé de de des
milliers de fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité pour prouver que ces êtres de
l'espace sont comme nous sont des êtres
humains comme nous et s'ils font l'amour
avec une une femme de la terre ça fait
un enfant alors que si un chien et un
chat sa couple ça fait rien du tout donc
ils sont à notre il nous on cré à image
c'est ce qui est écrit dans la Bible
mais mais il n'y a pas de Dieu c'est pas
ta mère qui te l'a raconté non c'est
cette être de l'espace que j'ai
rencontré et qui s'appelle yah Elohim et
T en adolescence ça s'est passé comment
en adolescence j'étais passionné par
Jacques Brel et j'ai pris ma oui j'étais
fou Jack Brel et j'ai pris ma guitare je
suis monté à Paris j'ai chanté dans les
dans les boîtes où je chantais et
j'étais sur sur sa route et j'étais fou
passionné de Jack BR tu te souviens les
chansons de Jack BR bien sûr tu peux
nous en faire une juste un Go si j'avais
ma guitare oui mais là très dur comme ça
avec la mer du Nord pour dernier terrain
vague et des vagues de dunes pour
arrêter les vagues et de vagues rocher
que les Maré dépasse ENF c'est bien tu
as fait le service militaire non non
parce que j'ai tout fait pour ce qu'il
fallait pour me faire réformer et si ça
avait pas marché j'aurais été objecteur
de conscience et mainant tu es réformé
tu peux arrêter des conneries maintenant
c'est
bon ton premier métier alors c'était
chanteur c'était oui c'était chanteur
c'était auteur compositeur tu as été
journalistes après bah oui j'avais une
autre passion qui était le sport
automobile et j'ai essayé par le
journalisme de d'avoir des voitures de
coures cétait à clairmferrant ça c'était
à clairmontferran et alors c'est là que
c arrivé c'était le 13 décembre
73 alors raconte-nous ce qui s'est passé
B le 13 décembre 73 je reviens du Tour
de Corse que j'ai couvert comme
journaliste et puis je je me lève et je
pars vers un volcan qui s'appelle le pit
de la cela qui est juste à 10 km de
ClermontFerrand et là j'arrive dans tu
es aller vers ce vers ce volcan où ou
une force qui a emmené oui exactement un
peu comme dans le film rencontre du trè
type je savais pas pourquoi mais j'avais
cette forme il fallait que j'aille là et
je suis allé dans à cet endroit là et en
me demandant qu'est-ce que je fais là
j'étais dans le volcan j'ai mais j'ai du
travail au bureau pourquoi je suis là et
là un engin est apparu quelque chose
comme une cloche un petit peu fait fait
d'un métal argenté très brillant qui est
descendu doucement sans le moindre bruit
ça avait l'air de poser plusieurs tonnes
ça s'est immobilisé à peu près à 30 m de
moi une trappe s'est ouverte et un petit
Têtre est sorti avec des yeux très
inamants Bou pardon Bouard pH Bouvard s
approché de moi il y avait une barbiche
tu dis une petite barbe oui un visage
beaucoup plus proche des asiatiques que
des Européens ouais ça et quand il a été
en face de moi ben j'ai osé poser une
question pour voir s'il me comprenait
j'étais sûr qu'il me comprenait pas et
j'ai posé une question il m'a compris il
m'a répondu en français parfait et là il
m'a dit grâce à une technologie ils ont
25000 ans d'avance sur nous ils peuvent
parler toutes les langues du monde et le
message a commencé il m'a commencé à me
donner le message à savoir que ils
avaient créé la vie sur Terre qu' avait
pas de Dieu que c'était eux qui avaient
été pris pour des dieux et que leur nom
c'était Elohim qu'on trouve dans la
Bible et donc la Bible est le plus
ancien livre até du monde en fait h mais
il t'a il t'a pas donné de preuve de sa
de sa visite il t'a pas laissé quelque
chose qui aujourd'hui témoignerait de la
véracité de de tes affirmations aucune
preuve si ce n'est le message et euh
j'avoue que moi j'ai été le premier à y
adhérer et j'ai trouvé ça tellement
logique parce queavant il y avait quoi
il y avait un bon Dieu surnaturel ou
l'évolution les deux étant des théories
hein contrairement à ce qu'on enseigne
dans les écoles CIT bien la théorie de
l'évolution la théorie du Dieu il y en a
une troisième qui arrive et qui
correspond à ce qu'on fait maintenant
créer la vie en laboratoire en faisant
des manipulations génétiques ça me
semble être la plus logique et alors là
tu es devenu Rael pourquoi parce qu'ils
m'ont dit arrête ton travail et va de
par le monde porte ce message les gens
riront au début mais au fur et à mesure
les gens comprendront et prépareront
cette ambassade qui est l'objectif de
notre organisation le mouvement réien
construire une ambassade où ils vont
venir officiellement et là je serai pas
tout seul tout le monde pourra les
voirou et alors il y a eu l'affaire
après c'était encore plus plus étrange
parce qu'en 75 donc 2 ans plus tard tu
te promènes dans le périgor et là tu tu
es parti en voyage sur une autre planète
ça s'est passé comment mais ça s'est
passé que le même engin est apparu et là
ils m'ont ils m'ont donné en quelque
sorte une récompense car le premier
contact était un test pour voir si
j'allais faire de l'argent avec ça si
j'allais essayer d'exploiter ça si
j'allais et pendant 2 ans j'ai été mis à
l'épreuve j'ai parlé sans jamais
chercher à faire d'argent
personnellement et ils m'ont donné la
récompense ils m'ont emmené sur la
planète où il vive avec cet engin qui
est une téléportation réelle celle-là
puisque en quelques minutes on peut
voyager à des distances inimaginables
c'est comment l'intérieur de ce de de ce
vaisseau spatial très décevant parce que
moi je suis passionné de sport
automobile et de pilotage et je
m'attendais à voir comment ça marche il
y a rien il y a je sais toujours pas
comment ça marche il y a un intérieur
fait d'un métal argenté le le sol est
fait comme une pierre précieuse bleue on
s'assoit et dit ne bougez plus je
croyais qu'il voulait prendre une photo
on sent un petit balancement et on est
arrivé ça dure combien de temps alors
ouou ça le temps d'y penser d'ailleurs
combien de temps mettez-vous pour venir
de votre planète j'ai demandé il dit le
temps d'y penser ouais comment ça marche
je sais pas alors cette planète été
comment cette planète c'est c'est le
paradis c'est c'est des gens qui ont
25000 ans d'avance sur nous donc il
vivent il y a pas d'argent il y a pas de
violence il y a pas de chômage il y a
pas de les gens font ce qu'ils aiment
s'épanouissent c'est ce que la terre est
en train de connaître doucement c'est ce
que les enfants d'aujourd'hui connaître
un jour parce que l'homme est pas fait
pour travailler il est fait pour faire
travailler les une bonne nouvelle bien
sû l'homme est fait pour faire
travailler les ordinateurs les robots et
pour créer pour penser pour s'épanouir
al qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils font des
manipulations génétiques qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ils font il s'amuse à créer
la vie alors là-bas tu as rencontré tous
les tous les grands prophètes as
rencontré oui Jésus
mahomé son qui sont partis de la terre
comme les histoires le racontent qui
sont partis de la terre avec eux et qui
maintiennent scientifiquement en vie
vous savez qu'en Californie il y a des
gens qui se font criogéniser
c'est-à-dire on les met dans de l'azote
liquide très froid pour les conserver
bon ils ont perfectionné cette technique
puisquils ont 25 d'avance et on peut les
recréer à travers une méthode qui
s'appelle le cloning de corps en corps
on les maintient en vie et quand
l'ambassade qu'on veut construire sera
faite ils reviendront officiellement
avec les extraterrestres qui nous ont
créé pour prouver de ce qui s'est
témoigné et c'est ce que toutes les
écritures racontent Jésus reviendra
Mohamed reviendra pour unifier tous les
êtres il est revenu
déjà et là il t'ont demandé de créer une
ambassade pour les accueillir sur terre
alors c'est quoi cette ambassade c'est
une ambassade qu'on doit construire si
possible à Jérusalem et où ils
reviendront officiellement comme partout
c'est écrit pour aider l'humanité mais
il faut qu'on fasse le premier pas à
savoir commencer à unifier la planète
commencer à arrêter de de de faire des
stupidités des guerres à s'unifier avoir
un gouvernement mondial à supprimer les
armées à supprimer les armes atomiques
et à commencer à s'unir dans ce village
planétaire où nous sommes tu penses que
quand Jésus a commencé à raconter ses
histoires les gens avaient le même
regard sur lui que sur toi aujourd'hui
le même regard et si les mêmes
médiamenteurs si les mêmes journaux
comme VSD le Nouvel Observateur l'éco
des savanes qui ont fait des articles
l'omniateur est dégueulasse sur moi il y
a pas d'autres mots pourquoi qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont dit bah ils disent des
saloperies ils disent que on drogue les
enfants qu'on viole les enfants aucun
n'a envoyé un journaliste pour
m'interviewer aucun n'a envoyé un
journaliste dans les rassemblements
qu'on a ils ont pris des photos dans les
agences de presse et ils écrivent
n'importe quoi qui reprennent de l'un à
l'autre et toute la France le lit et
toute la France croit qu'on qu'on drogue
les enfants qu'on organise des des
partous avec des enfants c'est
complètement Faou et vous vous êtes le
bienvenu à nos réunions pour vérifier de
vous-même et si on aaime pas les gosses
on peut venir qu
même tout à fait donc là tu as fondé la
la c'est pas une secte c'est quoi la
vous savez les premiers chrétiens
étaient appelés une secte parce que
Jésus disait des choses qui dérangeaient
aussi il disait aussi que son père était
dans les cieux et automatiquement la app
une secte on sait ce qui est arrivé au
premier chrétiens l' donné au lion
aujourd'hui ça pourrait être dans
d'autres pays des asiles psychiatrique
ou des camps de rééducation ben en
France c'est la presse qui nous salie
qui vide des tas d'ordures sur nous qui
fait que des gens par exemple comme le
docteur François piton de rouan est
licencié de son hôpital parce qu'il est
raélien et le il était il a combien de
raéliens aujourd'hui dans le monde il y
en a 30000 est-ce que ça coûte cher
d'être d'être raélien ça coûte rien je
veux dire les gens Paron dit qu'il faut
donner TR 7 % de sont revenus annuel à
toi on peut devenir si si on peut
devenir raélien immédiatement et c'est
gratuit maintenant ceux qui veulent
peuvent s'abonner à des revues peuvent
devenir membres actif et là il verent 3
% de leur revenu s'ils ont rien ça fait
pas grand-chose si ceux qui veulent
devenir parmi les responsables c'est 7 %
de le revenu s'ils ont rien ça fait pas
grandchose non plus c'est à liberté
c'est pas à moi le mouvement Ren ne me
ver aucun salaire comment je quoi alors
des droits d'auteur des livres que
j'écris pas de celui-là c'est Daniel V
des costumes 20000 balles tu l'as acheté
à to mais c'est vrai que le siège est en
Suisse quand même le siège du mouvement
international est en Suisse qui regroupe
qui associe les différents pays un peu
comme le Vatican unit les églises du
monde en fa le Vatican c'est pas en
Suisse quand même parce qu'en Suisse il
a les banques suisses pas nous empêcher
d'y penser quand même au Vatican il y a
les banques du Vatican aussi qui sont
pas mal non plus c'est vrai alors cet
argent est utilisé pour quoi faire si
toi tuen prends pas l'argent est
accumulé dans l'objectif de construire
cette ambassade mais c'est cher le
terrain à Jérusalem non très cher en
mars 93 au au au mur des lamentations tu
as été proclamé nouveau messie des Juifs
ça veut dire quoi ça mais messager Messi
ça vient de messager c'est juste un
messager j'apporte un message et le
messager n'est pas important ce qui est
important c'est le message c'est que les
gens prennent connaissance ils peuvent
le faire et vérifier si ce que disent
les journalistes est vrai ou pas 3614
codraë ils regardent ah toi aussi tu as
un mais oui il regarde et là il y a la
vérité ils peuvent vérifier par
eux-mêmees et avec le fils comment ça se
passe ça va très bien puce que moi
j'habite pas en France ouais c'est pour
ça que tu habites pas en France non mais
je veux dire je voyage autour du monde
donc j'ai aucun problème si je passais
plus tu payes des impôts où Ben
voyageant autour du monde j'en paye
nulle part tes rapports avec tes
concurrents comment ça se passe avec la
secte Moon les enfants de Dieu enfin
toutes ces Seces c'est pas une
concurrence puisque moi mon organisation
dit il y a pas de Dieu on a été créé en
laboratoire il y a pas de Dieu command
dans dans 20 ans
guéri j'espère pas j'espère être encore
aussi malade que je le suis maintenant
et si les extraterrestres viennent pas
tu tu vas avoir l'air faim quand même
non ils vont venir tu es sûr ah je il y
a pas de doute à quelle heure là parce
que entre maintenant et 2035 c'est ce
qui oui c'est la la date limite pourquoi
pour la date qui m' donné moi je ne suis
qu'un messager je transmets ce qu' on
sera là avant 2035 entre maintenant et
2035 ser peut-être qu'on le verra pas
c'est un mardi je peux pas moi tu es
marié oui tu as des enfants oui ils sont
raéliens oui ah bon quel âge ils ont ma
fille a 22 ans et mon fils a 21 ans et
ils sont il y a pas de problème tout
fait c'est pas pour te faire plaisir je
veux dire enfin non parce que ils sont
libres de d'aller où ils veulent j'ai
toujours laissé mes enfants très libres
si c'était à refaire tu referais
exactement la même
chose oui même le costume chaque jour
oui c'est vrai le costume c'est moi qui
l'ai dessiné bon il est pas parfait mais
c'est mon goût mais il a le même ma
vie dire alors il m'en a fourgué un dans
les loges est-ce que tu crois pas que
c'est parce que tu as tu as pas connu
ton père que tu as été tenté de t'en
trouver un chez les extraterrestres on
rentre dans la la psychologie
frudienne je pense pas mais tu connais
cette émission maintenant je vais te
dématérialiser il peut le faire tout
seul lui oui c'est vrai est-ce que tu
peux te dématérialiser tout ça-ce qu'on
fait des infirmiers absolument pas
pardon deux infirmiers qui le récl s'en
F est-ce que tu peux te dématérialiser
absolument pas le surnaturel n'existe
pas il n'y a que du naturel scientifique
qui n'est pas encore expliqué bon mais
je vais te dématérialiser moi alors
ferme les
yeux et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
litbe abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu